hey what's up guys my name is Asher no I
welcome to the fifth episode of my
morning coffee series today we're going
to start a series of videos covering
arrays arrays are to put simply a way to
store many variables in a single indexed
variable arrays can only contain values
of the type that they were created with
there are many ways to initialize an
array and today we're going to cover one
of these an array is declared by 2
square brackets opening and closing
following the type of the array one way
to enter values into an array is to
enclose all required values separated by
comma inside curly brackets at the array
declaration there is no realistic limit
to the amount of values in this array
each variable in this array has an index
ranging from 0 until the end or to the
size of the array minus 1 to access the
values in the array you can call the
array followed by the index of the
variable you wish to use in the
following square brackets watching the
video might explain this better thanks
for watching and I hope you enjoy this
episode of morning coffee I'll be back
tomorrow covering another way to
initialize and use arrays until then
goodbye